[Music]
so i was um
going through comments before we get
into everything today and uh
i caught something from four months ago
did you know
that smash math or at least the lead
singer of smash mouth
uh is good friends with stuttering john
i do know that
well well no only because well now you
know literally he just told me two
minutes ago
and i clicked it and this is legit this
is the real account smash mouth
commented on one of her videos smash
mouth that's what i got
commented on one of her videos four
months ago it was one of the stuttering
john clips
um i don't know what the guy's name is
from smash mouth i'm assuming it's jerry
smash mouth
wasn't it always the guy from smash
mouth yeah wasn't that old
so the guy from smash bros yeah the guy
from smash mouth the guy the guy with
the [ __ ] frosted tips
yeah is he uh he had this comment for us
uh these joker hacks are gonna okay
first off the audacity of smash mouth to
call anybody
first of all the audacity on smash mouth
oh you pieces of [ __ ] first of all
uh i'm not gonna sit here and get
condescended to
by the band that's basically just fat
sugar ray
okay because that's what you are you're
just fat sugar ray that's all you are
no sugar ray had more hits
yeah they did cigarette to it sugary had
more hits
okay name them please i'd like to hear
all these
i'd like to hear you four posts bed
royce is putting together
i am gonna putting together a track list
for their grandma
i gotta look it up here no no no no no
no no
no no no all these hits greatest name
all these i got
don't worry about it every morning oh
every morning i
already said that one uh yeah you can't
fly
you can't just string together different
parts of the song and words
and pretend they're different songs yeah
how does that go
give me a couple of books i'm a couple
of bars
hey i got it hey it's sugar ray answer
the phone remember me
that's how the song goes hey guys it's
the guy from sugar ray
you pick up the phone you're full of
[ __ ] yeah that's how it goes then it
goes
and then a regular guy goes answer the
phone to bumblecloth
that's how the phone goes yeah he goes
not only answered the phone
not only is that not how that song goes
i don't think any of that's ever
happened anywhere
that's how it goes i remember that song
it was very famous japanese hercules is
actually uh correcting me
they're actually fat fastball
[Laughter]
um i'm pretty sure that that's how it
goes
uh then they also had that great hit you
remember the song um
mean machine no i don't
i don't yeah the song goes so it goes
hey machine stop being mean can we agree
then
yeah smash mouth is just diabetic sugar
ray
okay so blood sugar
all right maybe smash off maybe smash
mouth had more hits
but like two of them were covers
okay so that really hits if there's not
your song
well maybe all right name all the sugar
ray oh sugar all the smash mouth songs
uh
all star okay we know that i'll start uh
why can't we be friends that's not their
song
uh that's not their song that doesn't
matter but still they still no it
doesn't count
everywhere okay uh [ __ ] i don't know
steal my sunshine
that was len you [ __ ] [ __ ]
fat lip all right so see what i mean
that's not their song see
you know as much as i do about these
people uh
[ __ ] graduation it's vitamin c by the
way
i don't know basket case no we're just
naming 90 songs i don't know they were
all smash mouth
yeah so wait what did the [ __ ] out
bleach blonde hair have to say okay so
sorry this is what we got
just like in real life other bands are
still more interesting than smash mouth
smash mouth says smash mouth says excuse
me
uh there's a single bone number five c
flat and that's not
that's lou baker smash mouth says these
joker hacks are going to talk [ __ ] about
stuttering john
ha ha because why did he write it oh no
i don't know
he wrote it he wrote it like he just
solved the case
in an old like old british
like he just figured out the formula
that's funny
stuttering john is a radio icon and
recently made nationwide news for a
crank call on prez
trump okay um first of all
howard stern is a radio election yes
let's dial it back okay uh and secondly
yes he made the he made the rounds for
pranking president trump
at a time when any news about trump
would get front page i mean let's be
fair
they didn't they didn't like that didn't
make national news because stuttering
john's interesting
it made national news because president
donald trump was interesting
yeah uh rick roy says stuttering john is
actually suing who are these podcasts is
that true he is suing carl like he
legitimately
it's not one of those like fake carl
said that he is getting
he's been served oh yeah
oh yeah for what nothing carl's done is
illegal he's allowed to comment on
stuttering john [ __ ] yeah but i mean
that's what john's been going on like a
[ __ ]
uh john's been as crystalia says he's
been getting real litigious
um yeah he's uh he's been going after
everybody
he's uh he's sol rosenberg now sue
everyone
sue everybody suing them for what though
for because he was very very hurt
claiming defamation yes he was it was
better never flies
i know john's just gonna waste money is
what's gonna happen
defamation and slander never flies and
by the way
unlike john carl has money siriusxm has
money yeah
like who are you gonna sue you're gonna
run out of money first dumbo
dummy but i don't know man maybe they
have that maybe john has that angel
investor smash mouth
do you think his his lawyer might be one
of the guys from smackdown he might be
the bassist
i mean [ __ ] if you're in smash mouth i
would hope that you'd still like
you know maybe finished up some kind of
college course
before uh before it fell apart somebody
says for carl saying he was a drunk who
couldn't hold a job
but he is a drug who can't hold a job
yeah i mean in my opinion see
this is the best way this is how you do
this in my opinion stuttering john is a
drunk who i do not believe
personally can hold a job yeah you could
say that or
why aren't you allowed to say that or
you just say john's a drunk who can't
hold a job
yeah [ __ ] it allegedly
that's not even some it would be one
thing if you were like
yeah that guy's a pill or something and
you go whoa
dude you can't just go saying that about
fifa you're gonna get you know what i
mean
calling somebody a loser and a drunk is
not
that's not even defamation isn't that
all he used to do
and does like stuttering john does that
to people all the time
the things that he's called that he's
called donald trump are slanderous
and defamation way more than anything
that's ever been said about him
not only that but the things he said
about howard stern and then forget about
that because
obviously if you want to hate howard
stern i certainly don't blame you he's
turned into a [ __ ]
but um he he's gone after every person
that works for stern like just people
that are still
there you know what i mean like whether
you like stern or not whatever but are
you are you gonna really hate like the
other people on the show
like are you really gonna hate fred from
the howard stern show for just keeping
his gig
these people have families to support
and [ __ ]
oh yeah so what's so what's going to
happen to him can we
let's sue john for calling us fat bald
losers
hey yeah that's right you call this fat
bald loser's job do you buddy well
kind of i'm bald but uh but he said both
of us
yeah that's right so hey john that sets
defamation mm-hmm
that's defamation of character calling
my lawyer
mark mcgrath yeah he's going after carl
and carl's just been laughing about it
he's like all right but then we're going
to discovery and i'm going to [ __ ]
he's going to he's like basically if
they go to discovery carl's going to
sling
so much mud at john and call witnesses
like john's basically
playing the worst chess game ever
because this is going to end with
john's business and dirty laundry being
aired out and none of carl's
so it's really not smart very not
not smart but hey at least he's got the
guys from smash mouth in this corner
nice uh don't [ __ ] with them hey yorana
i would like to call my first witness
the singer from smashmouth i don't know
his name either but